okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel today I
have my coffee morning coffee thoughts
but before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos today
I'm a little stressed out because I
thought
there was another day
in November I don't know why I should
know it's my birthday month but
I pay people on the last day of the
month I've had I had another day I have
to switch payment methods for everyone
because PayPal keeps freezing my ass
yeah so
so
because of this
because of this
um I'm a little stressed out but it
doesn't matter today we're talking about
my London hate group
so what is my London hate group and how
did it start I'd like to start by saying
we I also have a London love group I
have a lot of love for this city London
um I'm thinking about moving home mostly
just because I I haven't actually been
to my parents house in over a year
even though I've seen my family a couple
of times this year but it's just like
the older I get the more I'm like
I don't know you just never know how
long you have with your parents and
um especially like my dad I just
I don't I went to my friend's like dad's
funeral and it really made me like put
into perspective that my I don't know
you don't know how long your parents
have left plus I want to get married and
find a husband and I just think long
term like I'd rather my kids be raised
in America anyways that's a whole nother
tangent's heart I am looking at cities
um I'm looking at Nashville
um I'm not opposed to Dallas or Austin
but they're not my first choice right
now
um Nashville Miami or slash Orlando
um or I put Dubai on the list for the
hell of it just because I was like you
can get mad celebrities but then that
would defeat the whole purpose of me
going home but someone just said I
should do that I probably won't
just an idea I had but
I know that's like the opposite of
everything I want
um I thought about Vegas but I just feel
like if I'm gonna go to the US I'd
rather be closer oh I need to be like
I'd rather be within like a two three
hour flight
or like five hour drive or less from
Chicago so I don't know love parents um
my brother lives in Utah so I could go
out anyways I'm sorry off topic back to
the London hate group so London hate
group
I I would like to say I have a London
love group
there is a whole group of people that
I've made friends with and they have so
much love for the podcast and they
support me and I literally love them
however
I also have
a London hate group
now my London hate group
they had I put this
my London hate group has formed for a
variety of reasons so and the first is a
lack of female accountability women come
on my podcast
and they just say some dumb [ __ ] and
they get mad they get clipped
then demand I take the stream down then
when I say I will for the right price
and that price is very high because you
know I would make money on those clips
and that stream in perpetuity forever
um
so
uh
it takes a lot for me to take a stream a
whole stream down like that's a big ask
and then they're like ah you know
well you should just do it for free no
no no no anyways
so then they get mad and then they just
go on these rants or whatever to the
point I've had
um one girl threaten two girl one girl
basically threatened like the Indian
like Mafia or some [ __ ] or like some
Muslim she was like in some Indian or
Muslim Community and like
she just threatened to like bring these
people that she knew to kill me and the
other one um threatened to bring her
brothers to beat me up and I was just
like
honestly like I'm just being real
honestly
if you guys kill me like
if they're gonna kill me or beat me up
like I can't really stop you but what
I'm not gonna do is Bend to your will
because you're trying to like Bully me
I'm not gonna do that so you can bully
me you can threaten me but if I do it
for you then people will get word that
they can just do that and get [ __ ] taken
down so
um I'm a reasonable woman for the right
price I certainly will take the stream
down
so so anyways
what happened is these girls are in the
London hate group and a lot of times
what's crazy too is they're not mad
about the show until they see the
comments and then they see the comments
and then they want the stream team
anyways anyways so
you know and I'm sure there's ones that
maybe have real reasons to not like me
um nothing crazy like I've never done
anything mad but you know I can be rude
at times I do four shows a week I'm sure
I'm not always the most patient I'm sure
like at times I
haven't been as pleasant as I could be
but it's just guys when you meet 20 to
50 people a week you just it is really
hard to treat everyone like they're
special it just it just is and it's
really hard to have good experiences
with all of them so
these girls come together and just
convince each other that I'm the worst
thing ever
and I personally I don't really care
like they can just go be upset that's
fine
um
and
I really have no no issue with it like I
just don't care like I'm living my life
however
um recently two girls in this hate group
went on a podcast of my friends
um and I have two two friends one did
recruiting for us for a little bit his
name is Eddie and Daley and they both um
are on the show The domino effect and
you guys can look up this actual podcast
and these girls went on this podcast and
were just talking [ __ ] about me for an
hour
and again don't really care not my life
and what happened
um
I was I I saw that they attacked Auntie
Jenny which is kind of like this um
woman that I feel like I'm like been
taken under her wing and I just love her
um she's like in her 50s and she's my
talent I'm sure you've seen her on the
show
um
and she's just like literally so lovely
and
um
basically
um sorry what was I saying basically
they were saying she's so rude and you
guys can come for me that's fine I sign
up for this and I guess she does too by
coming on the show but don't come for
Auntie Jenny that I was like a line has
been crossed a line has been crossed so
what I did what I did
was I took the clip of her saying that
the Auntie Jenny's this that and I
pulled the clips from the actual show
and I put them together
and then the girls were like oh you're a
bully
how am I bully you guys started it and
that's the thing I would never start a
fight and then get mad when someone
punches back if you if you punch first
you cannot get mad when they punch back
I'm that's that's how I feel and so I
even with the whale stuff guys I don't
call anyone a whale individually unless
they say something about me first so
now the funniest part was the second
girl said I took her out of context
I click baited her because we put the
title she me too Dolmen and so I looked
because again I don't do the titles or
the thumbnails and sometimes there are
ones that I change because
like some of my contractors don't
understand the cultural differences or
whatever like there's one I changed the
other day where this girl she was so
nice and they literally put I am a [ __ ]
on it and pointed it to her and I was
like guys that's that's too much please
change this one and so there's little
ones like that that I'll change
because I'm like oh too far and so I
wanted to see did we take her out of
context so I go back and I watch The
Stream guys guys it was worse it was
worse
like not only oh my God
did she say something sexist I would
argue
racist [ __ ] too
so she was saying that in countries
we're talking about on the tube here if
a guy looks at you too long there's like
a number you can call you can like me to
him basically
and they were saying uh when she was
saying in certain countries where they
don't have that
um like women get assaulted or they get
taken at something like that and so I
said which countries because a lot of
times we make these broad statements
about countries in the East when really
like we don't know and we don't live
there and it's interesting like I had a
moment like this when I interviewed
zoobie the first time because I'd heard
all these awful things about Saudi
Arabia and zubi was like nah I'd like to
live in there and so it was
it was interesting like it just opened
my eyes and I was like you know what I
don't I don't know everything you know
like I don't know what these countries
are actually like maybe the women don't
feel oppressed or don't feel whatever
and and so I I said you know what
country specifically
she goes Morocco the girl didn't know
she was sitting next to next to Rockin
she was sick
and and so she said
and Eddie on the show said is it the
majority of men and she says yes
and I and so then I clarify I'm like
okay she's like they'll be grabbing you
and like this this and this and so I
said so you think the majority of men
in those countries commit assault so if
there's ten you're saying six of them
would commit assault
that's your view on men and she says yes
so not
not
sexist
because you basically said that if
there's no laws six out of ten men will
assault women you also said something
racist about Moroccan men
what and so I said I said so this is
where the men are coming from where it's
like you're me tooing all men
you're because like that that's where
the men are coming from for approaching
you because the whole conversation was
about like men approached me this this
and this and
and
um it was something about men
approaching her it was something about
yeah anyways anyways sorry I'm I'm
butchering this however I was like
and so when she said I took her out of
context
I'm like
if we wanted to be specific I was like I
could say she me too the majority of men
is that better so make it even funnier
so we start to like when she starts this
is what women do they start to like move
the goal posts and like change what they
said after they realize they look bad so
then
or like provide an excuse
so then she's like well I was assaulted
as a child like so if you don't wanna
like you shouldn't come in my space
and then this other girl on the panel
says I was assaulted too but that's
still not men's fault and it's not fair
to men like they don't know you were
assaulted like how can you expect them
like why like basically she said why and
she was so sweet she said in the
sweetest way like basically how do you
expect them to pay for your Trump and I
was just like
this woman is just digging herself into
a deeper and deeper grade
and so then she has the audacity so she
said something racist and sexist or
culturist I don't know
to go on another podcast so on top of
that another thing they said on this
show and I would like you to know they
both have like tiny ass podcasts I've
never heard of honestly this was just
entertaining for the week yeah this is
just gave me something to do so
they were getting on me they're like I
don't do that I don't clickbait I'm not
in it for money and then they invite me
on their podcast to like battle this out
now personally if you're gonna insinuate
because the one of the girls insinuated
that I was a racist and sexist
she didn't say a word for word but when
you say like the the platform's
misogynistic and black women have this
experience so it got even funnier
because it got even funnier because
because
okay because
so so they she says this stuff
a girl that I know
that's friends with this other girl okay
like she we're both friends with like
third party girl
and and she she's
I don't know if she's half black or but
but she she's black right and I'm only
saying that because she she said that I
was racist she comes forward and she's
like I had a great experience on just
pearly things and like and all these
women like start coming forward
and say and they were
all like
I I don't wanna sorry and and
saying like that just basically saying
that like the [ __ ] she's saying about me
I'm not sexist I'm not racist and it's
like
[Laughter]
and it was just funny I'm like your own
friends
um anyways so
because this other girl this other girl
um
said that Auntie Jenny was rude and
because Auntie Jenny this girl tells a
story about
how she went to China and like then she
wasn't like she was religious before
she's not religious now and Auntie Jenny
said I think maybe your faith was weak
and
she was like well that's rude you don't
know me and I'm like why would you offer
the story if nobody can comment on your
story nobody would know but you cannot
offer up a story and then be mad when
people draw conclusions and the problem
with both of these girls is they just
contradict themselves 24 7. oh back to
the podcast so
this is I forgot this part
so the the one of the girls invites me
on our podcast now personally
I just
foreign
I'm not gonna give so I charge five
thousand dollars to go on people's
podcasts
so I'm much more likely to accept
because I am grateful to guests that
come on for free especially early on
when I was building I'm very very
thankful to people that came on like in
the early stages because back then I was
a nobody I had
you know like now it's kind of like
everyone wants to come on but
back then it was so difficult and
um
like for example the the people that
hosted the podcast I was talking [ __ ]
about me
um they they helped us move into this
new apartment I'm just very thankful to
those people and
I personally someone calls me racist and
sexist I'm not gonna
why would I come on your podcast for
free when I charge five grand to come on
podcasts unless you have a follow like
it has to be an equal value exchange so
if you have a podcast and it's big I'll
go on sometimes if I just like you I'll
go on but if I if there's no value in me
coming why would I go on for free so
they also got on me because they said
I'm in it for money and clout which is
funny because there's people that work
for me that have taken home more cash
than I have I swear to God swear to God
swear to God
um because I just reinvest but
um so so
um
I say since you guys aren't in it for
money and clout which is what your words
not mine let's do it on the third party
let's do it on the same podcast you're
talking [ __ ] about me on
you don't want the money and you don't
want the clout so let's give you none
and then they don't want to do it it's
like ha ha
anyways
um
I just thought it was funny
um so that's I'm trying to think if I'm
forgot any stories
I mean parts of the story but I don't
think so oh um
so then I'm just gonna read you guys
some of the comments section
want to see if they responded because
I've been like
I've been
um
let's see okay I said oh it's funny so
this is my story right now so
the other thing this girl was saying is
that one of the girls came on and it's
not just her like a lot of women think
I'm attacking them personally but when
you do this podcast so many times like
you just see patterns in people and like
modes of thought and one pattern that I
found is like
there is the I'm a traditional woman
crowd that like clearly are not
traditional women so they just sound
kind of delusional and then there's the
crowd of like the femininity women which
is like women some of them are there's
um there are genuine traditional women
and they're genuinely feminine women
that have like worked on it and are but
I've just found like a lot of people in
these two camps like one as modern women
like pretending to be traditional like I
don't come forward and say I'm a
traditional women I'm not a 22 year old
virgin I'm sorry not I was raised in a
modern world I'm looking to be more
traditional I'm working on it but that's
that's all I can do second point
is the the femininity ones where they're
like
they're like oh like I'm feminine now
but like the only real work they've done
on femininity is like go to therapy
which usually messes them up in the head
even more I don't know why
um I'm not saying all therapists but
so
this girl
um this is what she said in the comments
section
I'd like to say I'm not actually
offended or hurt by any of this stuff
I I just I think this is entertaining
and and I think there's stuff we can
learn about how women move
um
let's see
let me find this
um this girl
the oh and so the whole point was this
girl was on my show and talking about
she's traditional but she was a single
mother
she was talking about she was at
carnival like she said all of this stuff
in her story that just completely
contradicted what she said and if you
look at her Instagram like it doesn't
look like a traditional woman
and that that was my whole problem and a
lot of girls think it's like personal so
like she said I was more modern and now
I'm traditional and I would say okay
what have you done to be traditional and
they always just say these broad
statements like it's basically like I
listened to some podcasts
like it's always these broad statements
of nothing so
and maybe she does I don't know you
personally
um
let's see
um
this woman has a cult coming for my
child
you could have not said that you like
this is the this is how modern women
think she could have not even meant like
there are girls that are mothers that
don't even mention their kid on the
internet but you you chose to go on a
podcast and mention your child
and now now I have a cult coming for
your chat it's like
um
her audience has a collective IQ of a
three-year-old you guys should be
offended you have you have a collective
IQ of at least four
um and then this is crazy I'm like do
feminine women argue in the comments
section like that this goes back to my
point
um
[Music]
then she was just insinuating I'm not
like pretty enough
which is
you know
um
interesting at her size but I'm not
gonna say anything
um
she said I'm very pro-men
oh here it is this is the comment
um
um but Pearl decided to attack and
manipulate what I was saying because she
knew she had a genuine conversation with
me I would have taken half her audience
foreign
like this is what I'm saying these women
are so deluded they're delusional
I have helped
my friend Ally she does the same system
I gave her my entire system for YouTube
100k 130k
Jess I got her to like 2 000 subscribers
my
my mom I got millions of views on my
page
I love helping women there's another
girl that was like a femininity coach
that came on the other day and she
seemed like the real deal I really liked
her if she wanted help with YouTube I
offered to help Cheyenne Reynolds all
the time like I am the biggest proponent
of YouTubers I know how hard this [ __ ]
is and you think
that you could come on my show
and take half my audience
like do you do you realize how
delusional that is
when you don't even have a podcast
but this is like what I say when women
like modern women modern women don't
live in reality
and if she did I would say good job I'm
happy for you but that's the thing like
when they're wrong or they say like
messed up [ __ ] it's always someone
else's fault and when they do something
that
makes them look stupid like it's always
my fault or the comment section fault
like it can't ever be I said semester
stuff and I was wrong there's [ __ ] I
said early on in um like I'll give you
an example when I first saw Kevin
Samuels I didn't like him I didn't like
him at all you could probably find
actually I might have taken it down
because because I I felt like some of
the stuff I first said was disrespectful
I'm gonna be honest I don't I don't know
if it's up or down it might if you guys
want to see it I might react to it one
day but I love Kevin Samuels I'm his
biggest fan but when I first saw him I
was so wrong I was so wrong about him
because I saw it was like high value men
cheat and I was like no but I didn't
understand
you know he was saying at the time
but this is what I mean
it's never like you can never be wrong
it is never their fault and if you
disagree with them you're either
ugly
or jealous
and I actually want to thank them for
giving me enough content to talk about
this week we also are going to react to
that on my channel and this is the thing
they'll play the victim and say I'm a
bully but I wouldn't have even really
known who you were
if you didn't make a 45 minute podcast
talking about me on my friend's show and
it's funny because then that she'll say
I don't even want the drama but she was
the one who picked the topic on the show
anyways
this is what I deal with guys
um
a return notice
okay well anyways I'll talk to you guys
later I gotta
I gotta I gotta figure some [ __ ] out for
Dubai
I'm going to Dubai this week there I'm
having a special interview but I keep it
under wraps guys
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time